fear alive bonjour on est en direct ce
vendredi matin pour parler de la
situation en ukraine je suis avec alexis
faire de chaque adjoint au pôle actu du
figaro bonjour alexis avec vous on va
décrypter un peu ce qui se passe puisque
il ya pas mal de changements ces
derniers jours cette dernière semaine
tout au long de soleil bien sûr nous
vous n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions
on essaiera d'y répondre au mieux
possible on va commencer par une
première question alexis est ce qu'on
peut parler de la situation un peu
général en ukraine qu'est ce qui se
passe actuellement sur le terrain la
situation en général c'est que les
russes sont on peut le dire en
difficulté c'est à dire qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à se rendre compte après
un mois qu'ils n'arrivent pas à avancer
sur tout le front qui affronte très
large et donc ils ont décidé de se
reconcentrer dans le bon bah c'est bien
dans l'est de l'ukraine mais faut bien
voir que c'est leur concentration malgré
ce que dit le kremlin c'est déjà une
forme de défaite sur le 15 km que c'est
une défaite générale est par ailleurs en
parallèle il ya des contre attaques du
craignent elles qui sont plutôt
efficaces mais dont on ne connaît pas
encore la portée la situation on peut
commencer peut-être parle par le nord du
pays par par kiev justement on va vous
montrer la carte qui est ici la ville de
kiev qui alors on va te dézoomer un
petit peu quand même voilà donc là c'est
ça c'est la ville de kef il y avait
beaucoup plus de rouge la semaine
dernière il ya une contre-offensive
ukrainienne à ce niveau là ce qu'il faut
comprendre déjà c'est que le
le front du nord donc kiev s'était on le
voyait l'opération la plus stratégique
pour les russes il suffisait de voir le
nombre de forces qui étaient engagés
c'était le front d'une heure et en fait
oui il ya un fleuve qui est fait c'est
benoît qui traversent l'ukraine en deux
et qui traverse aussi kiev est grosso
modo qui est fait à 150 km de la
frontière biélorusse par laquelle les
russes ont pu rentrer et en fait les
russes attaqués des deux côtés d'une y
être donc par l'ouest ou par l'est plus
une percée vraiment delhaize non là la
russie elle même est ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que la percée qui était la
plus la plus avancée qu'on voit là en
rouge ba aujourd'hui les russes nous il
ya une semaine il était sur la défensive
il crée des fortifications et là ils
sont ils ont plutôt tendance même à a
reculé je encore parler au conditionnel
parce que c'est pas c'est pas confirmé
mais il ya eu notamment l'aéroport de
gusto mail et un petit avion qu'on voit
sur la carte donc été vraiment à 30 km
de café qui était une base avancée russe
il ya eu des combats extrêmement intense
il semblerait qu'il n'y ait plus de
russes agosto man et même on a entendu
les ukrainiens hier dire que les russes
avaient quitté la zone de la centrale de
tchernobyl alors tchernobyl c'est au
nord de au nord de kiev à la frontière
avec la biélorussie donc il semblerait
que tout ce front là qu'on voit en rouge
au nord-ouest de kiev ont validé les
russes soient en train de de le quitter
tout simplement ça veut dire que c'est
un retrait définitif énormément de trop
brusque qui sont massés à la frontière
mais en tout cas ça dit quelque chose
les russes n'ont pas été capables
d'avancer et d'encercler
ffcc demi 2 8 millions d'habitants ces
150 kilomètres de périmètre si jamais on
veut en faire le siège les russes
n'étaient pas capables et les contre
attaques ukrainienne haïr pin notamment
on était pas si réussie on n'a pas eu
pour la seule la semaine dernière de ses
150 km prendre une ville comme kiev à
sigi de villes comme 4 ça demande une
énorme logistique pour la russie
absolument
donc là on voit les contre attaques
ailleurs pin hamac arif de l'autre côté
parce que donc il y avait le front de
l'ouest à l'ouest d'unia piège aussi le
front à l'est mais on voit clairement
encore c'est une ligne de front
logistique est encore plus longue pour
venir soit de l'est ce soit du nord mais
on aura une ville qu'on a vu sur la
carte principale qu'est cherniff et le
problème c'est que les russes n'ont pas
réussi à la prendre donc ils ont
encerclé mais du coup là en termes de
lignes logistiques c'est très compliqué
et les ukrainiens arriva à taper les
lignes logistiques russe dans la
profondeur et ça pour les russes c'est
extrêmement compliqué donc ce qu'on voit
c'est un mouvement général de retrait
des troupes russes sur l'ensemble du
front nord il n'est pas encore complet
je parle encore au conditionnel mais
mais on voit clairement la dynamique et
qu'elle avait été annoncée par le
kremlin en fin de semaine dernière et
les observateurs avaient du mal à y
croire vraiment assez à ce retrait oui
cirque eux elle est alors le kremlin
avait dit que c'était le ministère de la
défense qui déjà veut dire quelque chose
quand on a une grande victoire annoncée
c'est plutôt le kremlin qui parle si
c'est le ministère de la défense c'est
plus problématique c'est qu'on n'est pas
si canton deçà des opérations militaires
et là en l'occurrence il avait dit
bompard du nord parce que le
gros mission remplie ça paraît beaucoup
moins évident que cela encore une fois
la halle axes du nord et l axe principal
jusqu'à maintenant c'est là où il y
avait le plus de concentration de forces
aujourd'hui est une sorte de basculement
vers le nom base vers l'est
reste à voir ce qu'il en sera dans les
prochains jours les jeux sont
extrêmement ouvert il ya une sorte de
retrait plus ou moins volontaire des
russes vers le nord mais mais faut ce
méfier encore une fois on a vu
énormément de forces qui sont toujours
massés au nord de kiev mais côté
biélorusse
par ailleurs il ya cette avancée dans le
nom basse mais on
on va voir sais pas si évident que ça
par io dia les contre attaques
ukrainienne de l'autre côté donc c'est
les jeux sont vraiment extrêmement
ouvert avant de parler du droit à partie
vraiment de l'est puis encore une tête
de kharkiv kharkiv qui est elle qui a
été rapidement assiégé rapidement
assiégé en réalité non ils sont pareils
n'ont pas réussi à encercler kharkiv
c'est la deuxième ville d'ukraine c'est
un million et demi d'habitants pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée kharkiv c'est la
population de l'ensemble de la
tchétchénie
donc les russes ont connu deux guerres
en tchétchénie
l'une dans les années 90 s'est soldée
par un échec une deuxième en 99 2000 qui
a été une victoire russe mais imprimé
dit hier très élevé on s'est rendu
compte des difficultés l'armée russe là
il faut bien comprendre que la seule
ville de kharkiv c'est l'équivalent de
la tchétchénie donc non les russes à
aucun moment ont réussi à encercler
complètement kharkiv est là encore il ya
des contres aux contre attaques
ukrainienne et les russes tout
simplement se rendre compte 4 qu'à court
terme en tout cas il leur est impossible
d'assiéger et de prendre une ville de 1
million et demi d'habitants donc
l'appareil sont sur la défensive voire
recule à certains moments et on a vu la
nouvelle est tombée ce matin alors il y
aurait eu deux hélicoptères d'attaqué
ukrainien mi-24 aurait réussi en passant
au ras du sol probablement pas vu par
les radars et systèmes anti-aériens a
touché un dépôt pétrolier cac 40 km à
l'intérieur de la frontière russe vous
voyez kharkiv dans le prolongement de
kharkiv il ya une ville russe qui
s'appelle belgorod qui était depuis le
début le peul centre de gravité des
robots russe la base arrière que l'on
observé énormément le tout ces derniers
mois quand on se demandait si les russes
allaient envahir envers l'ukraine donc
là les ukrainiens c'est très symbolique
ont réussi à taper à l'intérieur du
territoire russe donc politiquement
c'est pas bon pour la russie pour le
moral c'est pas bon et puis ça dit aussi
quelque chose que les russes les
ukrainiens sont extrêmement agile et il
arrive à trouver des interstices pour
pour trouver les failles du dispositif
et demi ça veut dire aussi probablement
qu'ils ont des bonnes capacités
d'enseignement il avait peut-être vu
grâce au renseignement occidentales qui
avaient à cet endroit là une une zone
qui était pas trop couverte par la
défense aérienne russe mais c'est un
c'est vraiment un échec tactique
localiser certains échecs pour les pour
les russes il faut rappeler je suis
devant ce renseignement il est très
important pour l'épauler d'ukrainiens on
pourra en parle de la supériorité
militaire de la russie mais les clients
peuvent s'appuyer sur le renseignement
des alliés bien sûr il y a alors il ya
tous les satellites américains qui sont
pointés vers l'ukraine mais il ya aussi
tous les avions des avions de détection
avec des radars très puissant qui longe
le vin toute cette zone d'europe
orientale
ça donne des informations sur le terrain
aux ukrainiens qui sont extrêmement
utiles
pour se battre et on le voit depuis le
début c'est le grand avantage de
l'ukraine sin une capacité à utiliser
les informations
tactiques pour pour l'emporter parfois
localement face à un adversaire russe
qui est sur le papier beaucoup plus
puissant vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr à
continuer à poser vos questions je vous
résidez répondre comme on l'a dit du
mieux possible donc ça c'est pour la
ville de kharkiv on peut on peut
descendre un peu est ce que il ya quand
même des endroits où on voit avec ses
flèches là les forces russes quand même
progresse dans le donbass oui c'est
qu'en fait on ballon le voile sur la
carte c'est vraiment les russes ont
décidé de se concentrer sur le nom basse
et on voit que les deux flèches monte
comme une forme de tenaille de manoeuvre
d'enveloppement alors là pour bien
comprendre donc le le dombass en orange
c'est les territoires qui sont contrôlés
par les séparatistes pro russes depuis
2014 mais en fait la région du dombass
dans son ensemble est beaucoup plus
grande
et les donc les séparatistes ne contrôle
qu'une partie du dombass est donc
officiellement leur objectif c'est de
reprendre l'intégralité de ces deux
régions qui sont sûrs de the blast de
niépce est lougansk sauf que depuis 2014
les ukrainiens ont fortifié évidemment
la nuit la ligne de fortifications et on
estime qu'il y a de 30 à 40% des forces
d'ukrainiens de l'ensemble du pays qui
sont dans cette région et donc depuis le
début de l'invasion depuis le 24 février
on voyait que la ligne de front à cet
endroit là l'avant c'est très peu mais
parce que les russes n'avaient pas envie
d'attaquer frontalement semur ukrainien
qui était face à eux et donc ils tentent
de passer par le nord par le sud depuis
la crimée pour encercler ce dans une
sorte de l'héroïne s'appelle saint
chaudron poche toutes ses troupes
ukrainienne qui représentent une part
importante des forces d'ukrainiens dans
leur ensemble donc ce qu'on voit là
c'est une c'est plus qu'une bataille c1
une manoeuvre qui est absolument
stratégique pour la pour la suite du du
conflit néanmoins encore une fois de
niet ses 4 millions d'habitants ont
cessé le blast la région d'ukraine la
plus peuplée et en fait c'est un une
zone avec énormément de deux villes un
tissu urbain qui est très dense et donc
ça c'est pas évident pour le pot pour
l'offensive pour l'attaquant est donc
malgré tout depuis une semaine à deux
semaines on vous voyez cette manoeuvre
aux russes se mettre en oeuvre elles
avancent lentement et les ukrainiens ont
des stratégies de de freinage des armées
russes qui est facilité par par ce
contexte urbain et donc c'est pas de
l'encerclement des forces du non bah
c'est pas du tout fait encore on se
rappelle au début du conflit aura une
stratégie est claire de l'avenir
boutines là encore ça va prendre ça peut
ben si ça crie ça peut prendre des
semaines à celle des semaines des mois
et des mois là on ne voit pas de toute
manière d'issue
il y avait un deux chercheurs dans une
note de présentation stratégique qui
parlait de de ne pas se rater fixer vos
échecs c'est quand aucun des deux
adversaires ne peut l'emporter sur sur
l'autre et là on voit pas très bien
comment la russie pourrait réussir à
recréer un mouvement pour créer un choc
dans les nommer contre les troupes on
craignait n'est vraiment le rapport de
force changera du tout au tout et
inversement les contre attaques
ukrainiennes sont très réussis pour
l'instant mais sont des contre attaques
tactique on voit pas encore de contre
offensive se mettre en oeuvre pour entre
guillemets bouter les russes hors du
pour l'instant on n'en est pas là et on
a du mal à l'imaginer à ce stade avec
les forces en présence on peut parler
peut-être de mario paul marioupol qu'ils
consentent beaucoup depuis d'information
depuis
depuis de nombreuses semaines la ville
est bombardée depuis par les forces
russes depuis un moment il ya des
convois humanitaires qui sont organisés
pour évacuer les civils on en parlait
également
on pouvait penser que mary bale pourrait
tomber très rapidement là encore ça fait
déjà un moment qu'on en parle et que la
ville tient toujours attention il ya
vraiment le rythme médiatique a tendance
aussi à penser que les choses vont vite
mais tout ne va pas au rythme médiatique
et on sait très bien qu'une guerre
urbaine ça prend du temps ça prend du
temps parce que c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure on dans un contexte
urbain le défenseur al avantage par
rapport à l'attaquant parce qu'en fait
le relief urbain lui c'est entre
guillemets de
boucliers donc l'attaquant néné n'a pas
davantage et donc non savais que ça
prendrait du temps la fête sont dépêchés
à marioupol notamment les tchétchènes de
kadirov essais notamment eux qui avance
dans la ville aujourd'hui c'est très
compliqué de dire mais ils contrôlent
plus de la moitié de la de la ville et
en face côté ukrainien c'est le
bataillon azoff le bataillon très
nationaliste voire néo nazis
et qui a perdu maintenant c'est une
guerre d'usure qui contrôlent encore
quelques quartiers maintenant quand
est-ce que marioupol va être
complètement pris là pour lui confia
c'est une question de jours
mais ça alors ça va être symbolique ça
va être une première victoire pour la
russie pourquoi notamment sur la
question de ce qualificatif de
dénazification
de l'ukraine et bien là marioupol
c'était la base centrale du bataillon à
neuf et donc les les russes vont pouvoir
dire ça c'est une première victoire ont
vu la dénazification avec des guillemets
de de l'ukraine
par ailleurs ça va être la deuxième
grande ville que les russes contrôleront
après carson qui est plus à l'ouest et
puis surtout ça leur permettra de de
redéployer ailleurs des forces qui avait
été fixé à marioupol pour la prise de la
ville et donc ça c'est important après
encore une fois on parle
ça avance très lentement ça c'est
indéniable ça n'est pas une attaque
éclair peut-être qu'on en reparlera la
stratégie militaire russe ça n'est pas
une attaque éclair ça c'est une évidence
et au contraire le risque maintenant
pour les russes s'il n'ya pas n'arrive
pas à recommencer des manoeuvres c'est
une guerre dans l'isthme une guerre
d'usure et de ce point de vue là vladmir
poutine n'a pas autant de soldats que
l'armée rouge en 1944 ou même que les
ukrainiens qui eux ont sonné la
mobilisation générale et qui du coup ont
un effet de masse est pour l'instant en
ligne un outil dont on peut penser que
si mario paul tombe et que comme olivier
les forces russes se redéploie ce seuil
pourrait y avoir un effet domino sur wii
mais un effet domino localiser cercle
peuple et les forces russes qui seront à
marioupol seront probablement redéployé
justement dans la présente nay
du donbass et là c'est un mouvement qui
va durer pour le coup au moins plusieurs
semaines donc c'est pas un effet domino
ramassis fait et rapide comme le
craignait le chef d'état major de
l'armée des armées françaises général
burkhardt ya en vous il ya encore deux
semaines oui disait attention il ya un
risque d'effondrement brutale des
ukrainiens
on peut jamais rien exclure mais disons
que c'est vraiment à ce stade pas le
plus probable sur le front du sud on on
l'a vu aussi il y avait des
percées au alors on doit près de la
ville de carson vers mikolaj comme on
peut le voir sur cette carte vers une
autre centrale nucléaire qu'on peut voir
ici ça aussi les les forces russes comme
au niveau de kiev se replie alors pas
comme ni non pas comme au niveau de kiev
pour le coup les russes ont avancé assez
rapidement c'est là où ils ont enfoncé
le plus vite meliet paul carson verdien
ce qu'ils ont quand même pris un certain
nombre de devis lille c'était vraiment
approchée de mycologues que la leaf est
sauf que justement ils n'ont pas assez
de troupes pour
prolonger leur leur manoeuvre parce que
leurs forces sont concentrés dans le
combat est donc là ils sont en position
défensive ils ont même effectivement un
peu reculer vous voyez et contre
attaques et notamment prédit que la leaf
mais malgré tout c'est pas comme à kiev
ou ou kiev on a l'impression en tout cas
qu'il ya un retrait qui est beaucoup
plus important
l'aller les russes n'ont visiblement
aucune envie de reculer dans cette zone
pour une simple et bonne raison c'est
que vous voyez bien sacrer un corridor
terrestre entre la crimée et ils dombass
donc c'est pour les russes probablement
assez important en revanche aller plus à
l'ouest en passant par miku live pour
les escales au dessin et contrôler
l'ensemble des bords de la mer noire je
ne dis pas que c'est pas un objectif de
guerre de la russie jeudi qu' à ce stade
du conflit c'est impossible
pour les russes il leur faudrait des
forces qu'ils n'ont pas
justement on a en allant de sortir dans
les commentaires qui nous dit poutine va
réclamer tout l'est de l'ukraine on en
parlait au début de ce conflit sur les
possibles demandes dans les blagues ce
que parce que vous pouvez chercher
bioclean finalement après après plus
d'un mois de conflit où on ne le sait
pas en fait c'est assez logique il ya
trois scénarios peu généraux il y aurait
une invasion complète de l'ukraine et la
russie contrôlerait l'intégralité d'une
crête là je crois qu'on a très bien
compris que ce scénario est impossible
le deuxième scénario qui est un scénario
médian
c'est ça serait une partition de
l'ukraine on appelle ça parfois celution
à la coréenne où il y aurait une ukraine
de l'est et l'ukraine de l'ouest
néanmoins là on le voit très bien venir
poutine est très loin de pouvoir
s'offrir pour l'instant cette solution
tout simplement parce que contrôler tout
l'est de l'ukraine on va dire la partie
est du nieppe et les bords de la mer
noire et les bords de la mer d'azov la
mer d'azov oui mais ils en sont pour
l'instant très loin les russes néanmoins
et voilà et après la la troisième
possibilité c'est simplement une ukraine
qui seraient neutralisés
diplomatiquement largement des armées et
avec un vin un règlement particulier
peut-être pas tout de suite pour le
dombass et la crimée mais après il ya
des scénarios un peu entre les deux et
le et ses problèmes en ce qu'ils sont en
train d'essayer de faire et réussi à
grignoter effectivement dans toute cette
partie est issue de la de l'ukraine
historiquement plutôt russophone mais
qui dira ce feu ne nie pas du tout pro
russe
tout cas pas nécessairement et voilà
c'est un peu les trois ans scénario mes
mails et les moyens le rapport de force
militaire
ne pèse pas pour l'instant pour une
solution maximaliste pour venir poutine
il n'en a pas les moyens pour l'instant
on n'a pas de la mer d'azov qui et qui
effectivement très stratégique il ya
aussi la mer noire qui est qui est à
côté avec la ville d'odessa dont on
parlait beaucoup aux îles il ya quelques
semaines aujourd'hui si les troupes
russes
seront plutôt vers l'est du pays il
pourrait pour l'instant ne pas se
concentrer en tout cas sur le contrôle
d'une demande de cette mer noire pour
l'instant ça n'est pas possible les
forces russes ne sont pas assez ne sont
pas assez nombreuses encore une fois les
russes ont attaqué avec deux cent mille
hommes ça peut paraître beaucoup en
réalité c'est très peu pour envahir
complètement un pays qui est plus long
que la france l'ukraine ça fait six cent
mille kilomètres carrés et avec 40
millions d'habitants juste on parlait
tout à l'heure de siège des deux guerres
urbaines on a fait un
très bon article très intéressant
justement sur la guerre de siège et pour
rappel en
1945 au siège de berlin les russes
avaient perdu 80 milles pour les sièges
le verbe il avait engagé un million un
million et demi d'hommes juste dans
cette zone donc oui je sais c'est pas du
tout les même ordre de grandeur
vallières poutine n'a pas cette image
chair à canon pour mener une guerre
d'attrition une guerre d'usure qui lui
permettrait de prendre comme ça les
villes ukrainiennes les unes après les
autres cc de ce papier dont tu parlais
je pense absolument russe orthodoxe la
gare de sièges à papier à retrouver sur
le site du figaro pour les abonnés du
figaro justement en termes stratégie est
ce que l'on peut dire que comme le
disent pas
enfin je te hais ce que cette stratégie
du siège et finalement 1 a raté de la
part de la lumière routine raté c'est
trop tôt pour le dire disons que la
stratégie de départ en tout cas elle
c'est sûr elle a échoué et là il faut
faire un tout petit peu de d'histoire
militaire soviétique souvent parlé de
guerre éclair de beats cri etc mais ça
c'est une réaction très française parce
qu'on s'est pris le blitzkrieg allemands
en 1940 donne aux réflexes reviennent
armés qui a très vite ça on dira c'est
un bide script ça mais ça c'est
allemands les russes ne faisait pas de
du blitzkrieg qu'ils avaient une autre
doctrine qui s'appelle qui s'appelait la
doctrine des opérations en profondeur et
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
l'idée c'est de créer un choc en
profondeur dans le dispositif et demi
c'est pas une percée qui va travailler
très rapidement et qui va qui va tuer
l'adversaire c'est plutôt il ya une
longue ligne de front et ont créé un
choc très puissant en arrière 20-f en
avant en arrière et le dispositif ennemi
on va dire s'effondre qu'avec des
grandes manoeuvres d'enveloppement pour
coincer les
le dispositif ennemis qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas éliminé mais il est
complètement désorganisée et on voit
très bien au début que le 24 février
c'était plutôt
l'objectif de vladimir poutine on l'a
très bien vu parce qu'il y avait donc
cette multiplication des fronts au nord
au sud et à l'est et puis par ailleurs
les russes ont essayé d'aller très très
vite de contrôler les axes de
communication sans prendre les villes
mais c'était pour désorganiser larmes il
craignait l'idée c'était de créer un
choc l'héroïne s'appelle salle houdart
et est comme ça dans les premiers jours
l'ennemi est paralysé et puis et puis
s'effondre ça ça n'est pas arrivé donc
cette stratégie là elle n'a pas pu
fonctionner et donc les russes là sont
tombés dans des guerres de siège ils
sont c'est ce qu'on a dit beaucoup plus
difficiles coûteuses ça prend énormément
de temps
et par ailleurs ils n'ont pas assez
d'hommes donc là il ya ils ont
absolument besoin les russes de recréer
des mouvements de manoeuvre c'est ce
qu'ils essayent de faire dont le nom
basse mais c'est pas évident parce que
le nomma c'était 4 millions d'habitants
ces urbains ces danses et par ailleurs
on voit que les ukrainiens une agilité
tactique dont ne disposent pas les
les russes au-delà de cette stratégie le
siège est ce que globalement la
stratégie russe on peut dire qu'au bout
de plus d'un mois et est en échec en
fait en ukraine les elle est plutôt en
échec oui c'est clair mais ça ne présage
pas forcément des semaines à venir des
semaines à venir parce que voilà faut
toujours se méfier là le résultat dégagé
selon très incertain alors je vais
jamais une question tout à l'heure sur
la soeur j'ai plus le pseudo de la note
qui peut équipe type qui parle des
contre-offensives ukrainienne est
cependant pas allé aussi tout à l'heure
c'est contre offensive c'était contre
offensive localiser ça ne permettra pas
de récupérer dans mon territoire
encore une fois faut être très prudent
on voit que les contre attaques elles
sont quand même à la fois au nord à
l'est et au sud donc c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez impressionnant
avec même des des frappes contre le
territoire russe aujourd'hui
malgré tout on a du mal à imaginer pour
l'instant en tout cas une véritable
contre offensive générale qui renverrait
les russes entièrement chez eux tout
simplement parce que les rues si
vraiment ils sont
acculés ils ont toujours un moyen
assez d'augmenter le niveau de fram
d'artillerie qui est le grand avantage
des russes par rapport aux aux
ukrainiens et pareil c'est une tradition
soviétique
la guerre deviendrait encore plus
meurtrière mais mais disons que les rues
sont bloquées ils n'ont plus l'avantagé
au contraire davantage aujourd'hui et et
ukrainiens mais jusqu'où
la semaine dernière par le jugement d'un
point de bascule ce moment de la guerre
vous les ouïes de force c'est la
question du point culminant est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'aujourd'hui on a on
peut penser que on est a finalement à se
pendre bascule où il est probable qu'on
n'en soit proche mais c'est déjà ce que
disent elles à l'étude de la faune de la
ffrs la fondation pour la recherche
stratégique et simplement le point de
bascule il ya un moment où c'est
l'attaquant qui a toujours davantage
pour s'approche de point de bascule et
elle est là il semblerait qu'on est
peut-être on est passé de l'autre côté
donc il ya une sorte de rapport de force
les russes sont en tout cas
très grandes difficultés à aller
beaucoup plus loin ils peuvent aller un
peu plus loin il peut faire des progrès
dans de nombreux mais en revanche aller
beaucoup plus loin ça paraît aujourd'hui
impossible pour les pour les russes et
donc à une sorte d'équilibré ce qui
explique aussi que les négociations en
parallèle elle commence à se dessiner de
manière concrète on a vu les des
propositions ukrainienne qui était et
qui commence à être un peu plus concrète
mais c'est aussi parce qu'il ya un
rapport de force militaire qui est en
train de se constituer donc ce rapport
de force va pouvoir créer des conditions
pour une négociation on en est très loin
parce que parce que cette guerre qui est
une guerre d'attrition quand même malgré
tout une guerre d'usure
même si les fronts sont pas figées on
l'a vu mais cette guerre d'attrition
elle peut durer encore longtemps donc
chacun des deux belligérants on peut se
dire j'ai encore intérêt à
attendre pour remporter davantage dans
les négociations donc on ne veut pas du
tout dire mais pas du tout qu'il y aura
une une solution diplomatique qui sera
trouvée prochainement mais on remarque
simplement comme assez vite en fait au
début dès le début du conflit
que il ya les négociations ont commencé
aujourd'hui une base des négociations
qui est forte on en parlait tout à
l'heure la question de la neutralisation
de l'ukraine la question isoler la
question territoriale du dombass la clé
mais parce que sinon il ya une sorte de
point de blocage ne peut pas avancer des
armements de l'ukraine etc on commence à
avoir des points émerger alors j'ai
gardé ce qui nous qui nous rejoint et
j'en profite pour vous dire que si vous
vous posez des questions vous n'hésitez
pas bien évidemment justement sur sûr
c'est sur ces négociations
j'avais 10 ans à l'heure sur le une
possible rencontre vladimir poutine au
design ce qui on en est encore très loin
on en est loin il ya eu des déclarations
plus optimistes nageurs sur l'autre
on en est loin pour l'instant ce qui est
intéressant c'est les négociations
niveau fera ministériel avec les
conseillers les négociateurs etc
puis parfois c'est la question plutôt ce
qu'il faut observer ces niveau
ministériel c'est donc les mini affaires
étrangères il ya les 20 ans de la
naissance etc c'est là où on peut voir
le
les avancées et on a très très
clairement vu hier notamment qu'on en
était encore encore moi il ya aussi des
ddd gestion dite peuvent sur vladimir
poutine ce qui serait mal conseillé
le parrain mal formés par l information
mal informés en ce moment à part ses
conseillers c'est un vieux travers des
des pays communiste où finalement et
totalitaire on n'a pas envie de faire
remonter une nouvelle information est ce
que nouvelles informations se fait taper
sur les doigts par journée c'est les
purges et c'est donc c'est tout à fait
crédible est possible
il semblerait vraiment que les russes ne
s'attendait pas à une telle résistance
ukrainienne donc il ya eu un souci de
renseignement
souci dans une langue existait en france
aussi
le chef d'état major l'a reconnu qu'il
n'avait pas prévu
ce qui allait se passer non on réussit
c'est très clair et puis on voit aussi
chu young ou donc le menu de la défense
qui alors il est revenu on l'a vu en
vidéo mais a failli et en isoler défense
les gammes pas en première ligne en
pleine guerre donc il est clairement
discréditer le chef d'état-major des
armées nazies mof lui a quasiment
complètement disparu elle aurait été sur
la vidéo mais qu'est ce qui nous fait
dire que cette vidéo était présent
directement à certains
on sait qu fsb aussi pas mal de deux
cadres qui ont été noyés sanctionnés
donc ya
clairement et les rues sont cinq sens
pas content du tout du résultat après à
moi et vladimir poutine visiblement il
ya un risque d'isolement alors après
attention ça veut pas dire
il est isolé au kremlin et qu'il est sur
le point d'être renversé
à
lire à mal de chercheurs le
ya une forme de nationalisme ici qu'il
ya encore vraiment prégnante là il y
avait un sondage récent il faut le
prendre avec beaucoup de pincettes mais
malgré tout qu'il vient de levada qui le
seul centre traditionnellement
indépendant de sondages en russie et qui
disaient qu'ils avaient 83 % des russes
qui étaient
enfin qu'ils trouvaient que la le
président russe prenait les les bonnes
décisions a lancé probablement pas 83
mais en revanche cette dynamique il
aurait remonté d'après le sondage
puisque d'après les pédales il avait
beaucoup baissé ces dernières années
l'ail est de remonter une sorte d'effet
drapeau de
faux pas non plus l'exclure
lanières poutine n'est pas complètement
idiot non ici ça serait caricatural de
le dire et ça serait mal comprendre la
situation très bien merci beaucoup
alexis d'avoir été présent avec nous
aujourd'hui pour parler de la situation
en ukraine je remercie également le
service infographie du figaro qui nous a
fourni ces cartes votre bien sûr toutes
les cartes sur le site du figaro le
direct que je peux vous affichez
peut-être ici attendez je vais le
retrouver
qui est ici le direct à suivre bien
évidemment sur le site du figaro
alors que ce type d'écran voilà donc
voilà n'hésitez pas à suivre toute
l'actualité sur le site du figaro et moi
je vous dis à bientôt pour de nouveaux
lives sur figaro l'oeil